[Music]
in peaceful protest
news submitted by fight the power yay
artists installed seesaws at the border
wall so that people in the u.s and
mexico could play together
oh i saw this that's cute there's like
kids like on the other side going like
oh that's really cute
isn't it just gonna be like the
privileged kids making fun of the third
world country kids well let's hope so
like
what do you have pesos huh my dollar
buys thousands and thousands of your
pesos
like kind of smart i just saw mexican
kids on both sides just playing
that in the photos it was just like
mexican kids on the u.s side yeah
that was going around
yeah i saw this in a photo yeah i'll
show you a photo too
but this is some drone footage so you
could see the the entire which side's
mexico
left the left side's mexico look there's
so many more kids because they don't got
[ __ ] seesaws yeah cause the left side
looks more [ __ ] up
yeah so the left there's like all these
rocks and stuff
how cute what kind of kid is that yeah
no it's not just kids oh okay
so in the mexico side it
i think they're having fun mexico side
it was like near a community so there
were people pictures pixies
yeah look it's just two mexicans on each
side one side has
trash and everything the other one's
like well groomed floor
mexicans are americans bro i know but
it's just funny it's just funny
that it's just makes like mexican people
on both sides
i don't know so on the american side the
artists that installed these
seesaws they invited some of their
friends and
just people that could accompany them to
be part of this project
too so that's who you saw on the
american side but then like i said on
the
on the mexican side it's near an actual
community so there were just children
that were like oh cool
like something to play on and so they
just walked up and
had fun and so they the people that
installed this it's a husband and wife
they
are professors um one was like professor
of art and
design at san jose state university
and so they're saying that they had this
idea for this teeter-totter
back in 2009 and so they finally were
able to make it
a reality they were saying that this has
been a project
on their minds because not just it
wasn't like one particular
administration that has been in office
yeah because 2009 it was a whole
different administration exactly we had
the idea
exactly so they're saying like even as
far back as like 2006
when there was a secure fence act that's
when they
were just like really wanting to say
something about that so they've been
wanting to build a wall they wanted to
administrations have have given money to
fencing
the wall project's been going on for
like ages several administrations why do
people get so mad about trump
because he's the one that said it out
loud we need to build a wall
it's like the walls always been there
and it's incomplete as [ __ ] there's like
areas of miles and miles where it's just
open so he's just trying to complete the
wall but everyone
thinks he invented the idea i think it's
because of his warning too like build
the ones that have complete the wall
if he came out against the wall i feel
like the other side would be like we
need a wall
like sometimes i'm like man it's like
all so convoluted like i had
i had a friend of mine who's like a
super hardcore left
leftist like he was telling me old
republican talking points about trade
which now have been usurped by trump
because he's using old democrat talking
points about
trade that's crazy it's funny dude it's
all funny it's all going
back and forth he is always like that
see-saw bro
it's so [ __ ] funny the real see-saw
is trump because he used to be a
democrat and all of his buddies are
democrats and now he's
republican i'm right it's like what's
going on
and him and clinton were buds and [ __ ]
it's like it's all so funny
yeah so they're saying that from 2007 to
2015
the u.s customs and border protection
has spent about 2.4 billion dollars
on fencing gates roads and
infrastructures along the nearly 2 000
mile
southwest border did mexicans build that
fence i know right or was a white people
built the fence
probably mexican can you imagine sitting
there on this on one side of the of the
seesaw and hoping that somebody comes up
that's what i was thinking right and you
can't play that would be me that would
happen to nikki
yeah and then she catches something yeah
yeah exactly like a ringworm from the
freaking sauce but yeah so the artists
were saying that this is just a
beautiful reminder that
we are all connected and what happens on
one side impacts the other
oh that's tight so this this seesaw was
there it was just temporarily set up for
only 30 minutes on the border of uh
this suit juarez mexico city
and sunland park in new mexico
and how do people know to go there it
was only for 30 minutes
so remember how i mentioned that for the
american side they brought their own
people
and then mexico inside it was near a
community and they just saw
that i'd rather see tug of war that
would be fun
that would be really sick no but then
one side's gonna slam up against the
walls
they were saying that along the whole
border wall that this is like this one
small section that's like slats and you
can actually
pass things through and that's why they
picked this side and they picked the
color pink
because uh it's representing breast
cancer
breast cancer awareness month it's
representing the hundreds of women
and girls who have been killed near sue
that is during
a lot of robberies and gang wars since
the 90s so sad
i have a question uh if it was gonna be
up for 30 minutes why did it take 10
years
because they've had a lot of different
ideas of what to do
along the border and this was one of
those ideas that they just
for some reason they were like you know
what we need to do this right now like
today
is the time that we're doing this and
then they went out bought the supplies
you just built it real quick and then
they did it because they live in in
norcal
so i'm assuming they had to drive really
far imagine hiring these people to build
a swing set in your backyard they're
like this can be 25 years
yeah right now and then they
procrastinate because then they're like
on the
25th year like 24 point like whatever
year they're like oh [ __ ] we gotta go
get the supplies real quick
we said 25 years or so we gotta go so
they've been planning this since the
obama administration so it would have
happened during that time
if they really even proceeding that oh
really was like
oh like they just had this idea
it took a while to find like the wood to
make it in the paint to make a perfect
color
yeah it is the perfect pink yeah it is
well so
one of the biggest things that i just
haven't researched and don't understand
is like why is it really difficult
for um the immigrants to come in like
legally because if they want to come on
a work visa or like all these other
things like do they not
know where to go to it just takes a long
time because it sounds like these guys
are trying to escape
uh like a dire situation that they just
need to get out of
and here it could take years like he
left us took forever
so your parents came um when they were
young yeah
they were teaching did they tell you
what the process was i forgot well
you know okay youtuber okay yeah it was
um you know she moved here from russia
and she said that it took and she was
she spoke english she
did all you know she was working here
for a long time um she took eight years
well that's because she's russian oh
some countries yeah like mexico is one
of those countries too that is
harder it's like 15 years instead of
like other countries from europe where
it's like
but what about work visa because work
visa student visa all these other things
i think that's really fast yeah you have
to go back to your country and then get
it renewed and then you have like six
months
demi who's australian australia yeah
hers was about to expire so she had to
find a loophole so she
instead of going all the way back
somehow she found out that it was easier
going through canada so it's just a
bunch of like
things that you have to do to write a
british guy that got deported because
his work visa was up and like he was a
21 savage dude yeah a rapper oh yeah oh
yeah he got deported yeah cause i know
that depending on
like the level of friendliness the
countries are it's easier for some
citizens from other countries to come in
versus like
i don't know like china or like russia
or like if they're not on the
like the friendly side of things that
makes sense and if there's a lot of
immigrants that are coming from that
country they have to cap it because it
won't be fair to like the other
countries
no even mexico they have pretty harsh
immigration policies i was just watching
this thing where
mexico is dealing with a problem with
central americans
because of venezuela everything coming
into their country yeah because
all the south american and central
american like struggles
that are going on there with the wars
and stuff they have a lot of illegal
immigrants coming in
and then they're like whoa what the hell
man yeah
i just remember during when obama was
president
it was always like they're not doing
enough at the border and [ __ ] and but
obama's like deporting [ __ ] millions
of people right
and then and then so then the right the
right back then is like
it's not enough he's not doing a good
job enough right and then now trump's
deporting people but he's not deporting
anywhere near the numbers obama did and
the republicans are like
yeah he's doing it right what well
that's because he's on their team
right exactly it's so [ __ ] tribal i
love it so the republicans were
complaining about obama not deporting
enough yes and trump deports less
less yes and then they're still
complaining so far less at least no
they're happy now
no they're happy now they're like he's
doing it they were complaining before
because he wasn't doing it
he's doing what we wanted but there's
less people and now they're happy
what's their target goal of deportation
is it like 3 000 people a day
and then they're like yes i don't know
because that's a good question i think
they set goals and get stickers
we got three thousand today ice cream
party
i don't think they even care it's just
like oh this is like keeping up with the
jones's political style where they
are yes they just have to agree with
whoever is there
it's like when you're watching a debate
with these people and they hear their
guy and they're like
and then they wait for they wait for um
the other person to go and then they're
like no nobody laugh
it's just like man you can't it's like
when someone that you hate that tells a
funny joke and you can't laugh at it
exactly even though it's funny and you
hate yourself for kind of giggling at it
that's why i say like politics is like
team sports
yes it is there's really no difference
because there's really nothing yeah you
cheer for your own team that's all
you don't really listen to the other
side i'm like that was that that was
actually that's why we need fantasy
politics
because then it makes you root for the
team that would be
tired you're gonna have like a
congressman on this side and then but
you got the vice president on the side
but that just means you're a moderate
right yeah yeah exactly
but that's what makes you neutralize
because i used to really be against
anyone rooting against packers
when we were playing when we watched
football and then i joined fantasy
yeah and then all now sometimes i root
for the people playing against the
packers because i'm like
i got more points if they score or just
sports bet you know what we should
gamble with politics yeah can we do that
in vegas a lot of people do that
they did that on the last election like
who do you think is going to win a lot
of people said that trump they bet on
trump winning back when before anyone
thought was even possible and they won
[ __ ] tons of money
that sounds fun yeah so even if they're
a hardcore democrat yeah and they're
like man i got money on trump i hope he
kind of wins tonight
yeah right you got a hell of money on
the guy nothing's gonna change your life
more than that
you're gonna like the most like leftist
politicians nothing's gonna change your
life more than getting a couple
because somebody wants to see that's
what makes people think more neutrally
is like when you have people on both
sides that you like or that you're
already
promoting fantasy politics that's what i
don't understand is why do you want to
limit yourself to one side make them
fight for you like make both sides fight
for you [ __ ] hard instead of like
just always being loyal to one side dude
you should hear obama's old some old
obama speeches where he's like he's like
hey i got a message for you if you're
from central america don't try to come
to america
illegally like don't try it right and
then back then the wright's like
he's not doing enough what the [ __ ] like
you know what i mean it's like that's
the same [ __ ] [ __ ] it is
it's our level yeah fantasy politics is
genius let's do it
[Music]
you